ich bin heute Abend auf einem Geburtstag
eingeladen also stellen wir für meine
Freundin mal einen Erntekorb als
Mitbringsel zusammen ich habe hier
frischen Knoblauch geerntet als nächstes
geht's an den Rhabarber da kommen auch
noch ein paar Stangen mit ins Körbchen
was macht ihr aus Rhabarber ich stehe
zur Zeit ja total auf Rhabarber crumble
einfach mit Streuseln in den Ofen Minze
darf im Ernte kommt nicht fehlen wir
wollen schließlich Cocktails machen und
dann gucken wir mal was ich im Garten
noch so findet ich habe jetzt noch mal
einen Salat mitgenommen und weil meine
Freundin so gerne kocht habe ich ihr
verschiedene kleine Kräuterbündel
zusammengestellt z.B aus Estragon und
Rosmarin dann noch ein
geburtstagsblümchen dazu und dann hoffen
wir mal dass sie sich darüber freut